THE PRESIDENT IS FACING BLOWBACK
THIS MORNING WHEN IT COMES TO
HOW THEY HANDLED THE CHINESE
SURVEILLANCE BALLOON THAT WAS
SHOT DOWN ON SATURDAY.
TO TALK MORE ABOUT THIS, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER UNDER
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, JOHN
BOLTON HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AMBASSADOR,
FOR BEING HERE.
I THINK THE FIRST QUESTION IS,
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE SHOT DOWN THIS BALLOON
SOONER?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, WHEN IT WAS FIRST
SIGHTED NEAR ALASKA ON THE 28th
OF JANUARY, ACCORDING TO PRESS
REPORTS NORAD, THE NORTH
AMERICAN SPACE COMMAND, DECIDED
IT WAS NOT THREATENING.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW THEY
KNOW.
THE PAYLOAD FOR THIS BALLOON WAS
APPARENTLY THE SIZE OF THREE
BUSES.
THAT'S PRETTY BIG.
WERE WE CONFIDENT THERE WAS NOT
A NUCLEAR WEAPON IN THAT
PAYLOAD?
WERE WE CONFIDENT IT WAS NOT
CARRYING BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS,
PATHOGENS OR TOXINS THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN DUMPED INTO A
RESERVOIR OR SPREAD ACROSS CROP
LANDS?
WHY WERE THEY SO SURE?
AND TWO DAYS LATER, THEY DID
DETERMINE IT WAS AN INTELLIGENCE
THREAT, AND DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT, AND DIDN'T TELL THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
UNTIL THREE DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
CONTACT, WHICH I FIND
INCREDIBLE.
>> YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT, IT WAS JANUARY 31st THAT
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT ALERTED
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THAT'S WHEN HE
ASKED FOR THOSE OPTIONS ABOUT
POTENTIALLY SHOOTING IT DOWN.
YOU THINK HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
TOLD THE DAY IT WAS DETECTED?
>> WELL, I THINK MUCH SOONER.
THERE'S A LOT THAT WE DON'T KNOW
HERE.
AND THE WORDING OF MANY OF THE
STATEMENTS BY ADMINISTRATION
SPOKESMAN IS SLOPPY.
AND WHEN THE WORDING IS SLOPPY,
THAT OFTEN MEANS THE UNDERLYING
STORY IS SLOPPY.
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT DELAY IN MY
VIEW.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE
EXPLANATION.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO KNOW WHERE
IN THE CHAIN OF COMMAND FROM
THAT FIRST SIGHTING, THE FIRST
DETECTION OF THE BALLOON, HOW
FAR UP DID IT GO, WHERE DID IT
STOP, AND WHY DID IT STOP?
>> THE ARGUMENT IS THAT SHOOTING
IT DOWN OVER WATER WAS THE
SAFEST OPTION, BECAUSE WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM OFFICIALS IS
THAT THEY BELIEVED THAT IT COULD
HAVE CAUSED DAMAGE TO PEOPLE, IT
COULD HAVE HURT PEOPLE, TO
BUILDINGS, IT COULD HAVE HURT
PEOPLE IF THEY SHOT IT DOWN
WHILE IT WAS OVER MONTANA OR
IDAHO, FOR EXAMPLE.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT?
>> WELL, I THINK WE OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF OUR CITIZENS.
HOW WOULD THEIR SAFETY BE
AFFECTED IF THERE WERE WEAPONS
ON THAT THING THAT WE DIDN'T ACT
WHEN IT WAS TIMELY TO DO SO.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
GREAT CITIZENS OF ALASKA AND
MON
MONTANA, IT'S LESS POPULATED
THAN HERE AT HOME.
WE'VE HAD BOMB SHELTERS BEFORE,
WE CAN BE PREPARED FOR THIS.
THE GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE
COMPENSATION FOR PROPERTY
DAMAGE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE UNANSWERED ABOUT WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT DO.
BUT THERE'S A LOT POSSIBILITY
HERE, TOO.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS AS IF
SHOOTING IT DOWN MEANS
DESTROYING IT.
BACK IN THE DAY, BEFORE THERE
WAS ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION OF
PHOTOGRAPHS FROM SPACE, WE USED
TO DUMP FILM THAT OUR SATELLITES
HAD TAKEN INTO CANISTERS THAT
CAME BACK TO EARTH AND WERE
CAUGHT BY AIRPLANES.
I DON'T KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY, IF
WE STILL HAVE IT OR HAVE JUNKED
IT, OR IF IT WAS POSSIBLE HERE.
BUT THE SAYING GOES, WHERE
THERE'S A WILL, THERE'S A WAY.
CAPTURING THAT PAYLOAD IS GOING
TO BE VERY IMPORTANT.
WHATEVER WE CAN GET OFF THE
BOTTOM OF THE SEA, IF THERE WERE
SOME OTHER WAY TO HAVE BROUGHT
IT DOWN MORE SLOWLY, IF WE COULD
HAVE PROVEN THIS WAS CHINESE
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING, WE
SHOULD HAVE TAKEN A CLOSER LOOK
AT IT.
>> THE OTHER THING WE HEARD FROM
THE PENTAGON IS THAT THIS WAS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING BEFORE, WHEN
YOUR BO BOSS, YOUR FORMER BOSS,
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE, WE'RE NOW LEARNING FROM
A SENIOR ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
WHO SAYS THOSE PREVIOUS
OCCURRENCES WERE DISCOVERED
AFTER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
LEFT OFFICE.
I THINK YOU AS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER, HOW CAN A CHINESE SPY
BALLOON GET INTO CHINESE AIR
SPACE AND SOMEONE LIKE WAS NOT
TOLD, SOMEONE LIKE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS NOT HOLD,
MARK ASPER WAS NOT HOLD ABOUT
THIS.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, EVERY TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL WHO HAS
BEEN ASKED HAVE SAID THEY DIDN'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I WILL SAY THIS, IF THERE WAS
ANY ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE THAT THESE
BALLOONS WERE OVER THE UNITED
STATES AND HIGHER AUTHORITY
WASN'T TOLD, THAT'S A SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
THAT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING.
I WROTE THESE WORDS DOWN.
I WAS SO, SO STUNNED BY THEM.
ONE OFFICIAL TOLD FOX NEWS THAT
THE BALLOONS WENT UNDETECTED,
UNDETECTED.
AND THEN SAID, TWO THINGS CAN BE
TRUE AT ONCE.
THIS HAPPENED AND IT WASN'T
DETECTED.
IF IT WASN'T DETECTED WHEN IT
HAPPENED, HOW DID WE DETECT IT
MORE RECENTLY?
DID THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
INVENT A TIME MACHINE?
WHAT IS THE BASIS OF THIS NEW
DETECTION?
NOW, I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS OFFERED TO
BRIEF FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY HAVEN'T CALLED ME.
I'M NOT WAITING BY THE PHONE FOR
IT, ALTHOUGH I WOULD TAKE THE
BRIEFING IF THEY OFFERED IT.
I THINK CONGRESS HAS GOT A LOT
OF QUESTIONS HERE.
THIS WAS A BOTCHED EFFORT FROM
THE BEGINNING.
AND BY THE WAY, THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE EARLIER TRANSITS OF
PART OF THE UNITED STATES
TERRITORY, WHICH I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION MADE PUBLIC TO
SAY IT'S NOTHING NEW, DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT, PROVES EXACTLY
THE OPPOSITE.
THE VERY FACT, IF IT IS A FACT,
THAT THE CHINESE HAVE TRIED THIS
BEFORE SHOULD HAVE ALERTED US
AND SHOULD HAVE CAUSED US TO
TAKE ACTION BEFORE THE BALLOON
CROSSED INTO AMERICAN SOVEREIGN
TERRITORY.
>> NOTABLE TO SAY THAT YOU DO
WANT THAT BRIEFING.
AMBASSADOR BOLTON, WHILE I HAVE
YOU HERE, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT WHAT I MENTIONED EARLIER,
THESE NEW POLLS WE'RE SEEING
FROM ABC AND "THE WASHINGTON
POST" ON 2024, WHERE IT SAYS FEW
AMERICANS ARE EXCITED ABOUT A
TRUMP/BIDEN REMATCH.
I KNOW YOU HAVE TOYED WITH THE
IDEA OF RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
HAVE YOU MADE A DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024?
>> I HAVE NOT, BUT I WOULD SAY,
WHETHER I RUN OR NOT, I DO THINK
NATIONAL SECURITY IS GOING TO BE
A MUCH MORE IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
2024 THAN IN RECENT ELECTIONS.
AND IF THIS CHINESE BALLOON
INCIDENT PROVES ANYTHING, IT'S
THAT THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED
STATES NEED TO HEAR MORE FROM
CANDIDATES WHAT THEIR FOREIGN
POLICY VIEWS ARE.
THESE ARE LIFE AND DEATH
DECISIONS THAT PRESIDENTS MAKE.
I KNOW IT'S NOT BEEN THE SOURCE
OF A LOT OF POPULAR DISCUSSION
IN RECENT CAMPAIGNS.
THAT'S A MISTAKE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THE CANDIDATES NEED TO TALK
ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY MUCH,
MUCH MORE.
>> DO YOU THINK TRUMP HAS A GOOD
MESSAGE ON NATIONAL SECURITY?
>> TRUMP DOESN'T HAVE ANY
MESSAGE ON NATIONAL SECURITY
OTHER THAN THAT HE WOULD BE
PERFECT, PERFECT PHONE
CONVERSATIONS, PERFECT DECISIONS
ON THE BALLOON, PERFECT
DECISIONS TO SOLVE THE
RUSSIA/UKRAINE WAR.
IT'S ALL ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ABOUT FOREIGN POLICY.
>> FORMER AMBASSADOR JOHN
BOLTON, THANK YOU FOR THAT
PERSPECTIVE THIS MORNING.